[موسيقى]
الف موسوعه اعتبرت المرجع الرئيس للطبي في
اوروبا لعشرات السنين
بولس الاجانطي او بولس الهجني الطبيب
اليوناني البيزنطي ولد على الراجح في
العام
625 ميلاديا في جزيره سالونيك بايجينا
الواقعه غرب شاطئاتنا في اليونان
درس في الاسكندريه بمصر وعصر العصر الذهبي
للحضاره الاسلاميه وعرف عند العرب جراحا
متخصصا في امراض النساء فلقبوه بالقوابل
كما برع في امراض البصر وتقويمه وانشا
حلولا مبتكره لحديث الولاده للحصول على
رؤيه مستقيمه من بينها صنع قناع لتقويم
البصر
وعلى الرغم من عدم حفظ رسم تخطيطي للاقنعه
حتى يومنا هذا الا ان بولس كان اول من
اقترح التصحيح المبكر لانحراف العينين
واعتبر ابا لتقويم البصر
وضع خلاصه الطب في موسوعه انضمت مجموعه
كتب وصل عددها الى سبعه واحتوت مجموعه كل
المعارف الطبيه الغربيه في الامبراطوريه
البيزنطيه
من اهم اثاره الكناش في الطب وهو عباره عن
سبع مقالات ترجمت الى العربيه وكتاب في
علل النساء
لم ترد معلومات مفصله عن وفاته ويرجح انه
توفي عام 690 للميلاد
[موسيقى]